Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Minus. Warte noch mal ganz kurz, wir müssen Pulli ausziehen. Mir ist es hier zu warm. Ja. Wer hätte damit noch gerechnet.
Ist Sommer geworden. Ja. Ja, das ist schön, oder? Die lange Durststrecke ist äh vorbei.
So, jetzt besser?
Sehr viel.
Das gut. Tja, der Frühling äh ist gekommen,
Auch der Mai pirscht äh schon langsam heran und ja. Jetzt hatten wir eine kleine Pause, weil hier nix passiert war, ne?
Es war irgendwie in der vergangenen Woche nicht genug, um äh dafür.
Auszuholen.
Dann noch abends auf ein Bier zu verzichten, um früher aufstehen zu können, deswegen äh da können wir auch mal ehrlich sein. Ja, was haben wir.
Da kann man auch mal eine Pause machen. Genau, aber jetzt äh passt das hier auch mit dem äh mit dem Wetter und all dem.
Und Apfel Air drücken.
Auf dem Beamer ist, ja, Entschuldigung. Wenn ich, wenn ich so mache, ist immer einfach die genau auf der Tastatur. Da muss halt kannst du halt von hier ja sehen, ne? Space, eine Affe.
Ja ja, passt schon. Guck mal, passt. Ja.
Ja äh für die, für die, die nicht für diejenigen wenigen Hörer, die nicht hier sind, zur Liveveranstaltung. Ähm ich habe gerade zwei Finger hochgehoben und so gemacht.
Das war die Information, auf die jetzt alle gewartet haben. Also womit fangen wir denn an?
Wir fangen an mit ähm.
Unseren Freunden von Netzpolitik Punkt org.
Mit unseren Freunden von Netzbotik Punkt Org. Ähm,
ich hab ja auch mal bei gearbeitet also ich ich schreib ja immer noch sehr unregelmäßig dort hab aber auch,
ähm genau wie Andre Meister äh da einige Zeit mit einer Anstellung geschrieben und ähm,
In der Tat hat es sich sogar so ergeben, dass André Meister dahin gewechselt hat, als ich gerade gegangen war, man könnte ihn also als mein Nachfolger bezeichnen. Und ich bin ja sehr, sehr,
begeistert von insbesondere seiner Arbeit da. Also was sehr in den letzten anderthalb Jahren da gemacht hat, was der für ja, wirklich national bedeutsame Recherche da betrieben hat,
Ähm insbesondere zu Funkzellenabfrage, seine penetrant damit den Informationsfreiheitsgesetz anfragen, wo er immer wieder neue Sachen rauspult, ähm die beeindruckt mich immer wieder. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen komisch, das zu sagen, weil ich ja auch persönlich mit ihm befreundet bin und mich mal frage, wie sich das jetzt für ihn anhört, wenn er das sich anhört.
Auf jeden Fall braucht seine Redaktion, wo er schreibt mit Markus Becker, die brauchen Geld. Und mir ist das ein sehr großes Anliegen, dass sie es auch bekommen.
Ja, ist ja auch nachvollziehbar. Ich meine, Netzpolitik Punkt org gibt's jetzt seit wann? Sieben Jahre, acht Jahre.
Seit zweitausendvier.
Zweitausendvier, das äh geht dann schon langsam ins neunte Jahr über, also das ist alles schon äh recht signifikant. Ich weiß noch ähm als das irgendwie alles anfing. Ich habe auch, glaube ich, mit Markus ziemlich zu Beginn,
Mal bei bei CRE damals noch Chaos Radio Express äh äh zu Gast. Da hauen wir uns schon das erste Mal so thematisch ähm,
unterhalten und so über seine,
europäischen Lobby-Aktivitäten gesprochen und das war dann sozusagen noch eine Zeit, wo ähm das blockt nicht die,
Regionale Bedeutung bekommen hatte, ganz klar, das stand alles noch am Anfang, aber über diesen Zeitraum ist es einfach eine der beständigsten,
Projekte in dieser ganzen Netzwelt überhaupt, ja? Also einfach immer da gewesen, auch immer.
Da gewesen. Also die Themen wurden besetzt, so wie sie kamen. Und äh selten wurde da mal irgendwas äh aus dem Weg gegangen und häufig war es so, dass eben,
Politik Org auch wirklich die Informationen zuerst kam und auch am nachhaltigsten dargestellt wurden,
Bis dann irgendwann auch so der Paradigmenwechsel kam, dass eben auch Netzpolitik org zum Anlaufpunkt wurde, um Informationen zu verbreiten.
Also ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr ganz genau, was der erste
Vorfall war, aber so das Zuspielen von Daten und das Zuspielen von Informationen. Das äh wurde dann irgendwann
zum Sport und wo es vorher andere Protagonisten gab, die vielleicht äh von denen man eher gedacht hat, dass sie so ein mit irgend sowas an die Öffentlichkeit gehen,
Ähm ja hat Netzpolitik org das dann eben äh übernommen und heute ist es eben so eine dieser Webseiten, die man so recht sich nicht wegdenken kann. Aus dem Netz,
oder? So ist es. Und trotzdem ist es halt gefährdet, weil auch sowas will natürlich finanziert werden. Da fragt man sich natürlich, wie ist es denn bisher finanziert worden?
Ja, Netzkritik Org ist finanziert worden von der äh von den Newthinking GmbH, die der Markus äh Teilhaber und Geschäftsführer ist
Markus Beckedal und ähm eigentlich ist das bisher immer ein
Produkt von New Thinking gewesen, quasi dieses Blog oder jetzt ist es ist ein Produkt von Newthinking, was also aus den,
Aktivitäten dieser Agentur dann quer subventioniert wird, das heißt es ist das Netz für Tick ORG ist eine großes, rotes Minus in der Bilanz von äh Newthinking.
Das seit jetzt neun Jahren und das hat natürlich äh New Thinking immer auch mit Überzeugung und gerne gemacht.
Also was sozusagen sein eigener Sponsor ein bisschen so, ne? Ja. Also Markus in dem Sinne.
Markus in dem Sinne, aber natürlich auch der, der ist ja nicht der alleinige Inhaber dieser Firma. Das heißt, die die gesamte Firma hat sich das gönnt sich das.
Und ähm jetzt kann man natürlich, das ist natürlich nicht nur karitativ natürlich äh hat da auch die hat da sicherlich die Firma auch bestimmte äh Vorteile durch, weil sie ja in dem in dem Webbereich auch arbeitet, dass man weiß, jo, das sind die, die machen sowas, aber Netzpolitik, Ork ist da
immer ohne jegliche Einflussnahme von New Thinking gewesen und die, ich glaube, die Wenigsten wissen auch, dass New Thinking da letztendlich irgendwo hintersteckt und die,
das fehlende Geld reinbuttert, um den Laden da am Laufen zu halten.
Ja, also ich denke auch, das ist jetzt äh vielen gar nicht so ähm bewusst so. Äh es gab ja dann auch einen ähm Wandel,
Indem man äh umgestellt hat auf Werbung. Das war ja lange Zeit nicht so. Es gibt da so eine Kooperation mit Zeit äh Online, die vermarkten da halt Werbung,
Allerdings sagt halt ähm,
Markus sagt das Projekt eben, dass das eben nicht so gut funktioniert, weil oh Wunder, oh Wunder, die Zielgruppe doch halt sowieso mit AdBlockern äh unterwegs ist und auch nicht jetzt unbedingt so der Klickstrecken äh trainierte
Typ sich dort widerspiegelt, so von daher wirft das relativ wenig ab und ist eben nicht in der Lage, die Kosten zu tragen.
Es äh vor allem kann also du findest natürlich auch wenig äh äh Werbekunden in dem Bereich. Also wenn wenn du dir anschaust, wer,
wirbt auf IT-Seiten, ja
kannst du halt bei jedem einzelnen immer sehen, warum der gerade nicht auf Netzpolitik org wirbt, ja? Also soll die Telekom jetzt bei Netzbitic org werden, sei Vodafone erwerben. Ja, also ähm.
Kein werbefreundliches Umfeld, wie man so schön sagt.
Ist einfach überhaupt kein werbefreundliches Umfeld, obwohl es irgendwie eins der
weitere Reichweiten stärksten Blocks in in Deutschland ist. Ähm andere Einnahmequellen, wie so äh Produktreviews oder sowas äh sind da natürlich auch nicht angesagt bei Netzpolitik, Org,
Interessant finde ich, dass es ja dann mal schon vor einiger Zeit, da ging es ja los mit der mit der Vorstellung so, was da was da überhaupt die Ausgaben sind.
Und da gab's jetzt auch einen sehr, sehr schönen äh sehr, sehr schönen Beitrag, wo sie das denn haben sie jetzt auch so eine Grafik, die ist nämlich super, wo man halt sieht, okay, was kommt rein, ne,
ein bisschen einmal so ein Affiliate, ein bisschen Vorträge, wo irgendwie Markus oder Andre mal irgendwie irgendwohin eingeladen werden
und Referenten, Honorar bekommen und durch die Vermarktung von durch Zeit Online äh zweitausend Euro
Ähm und was steht dem gegenüber, ne? Also irgendwie Personalkosten für Markus Andre, Praktikanten, Administration, Buchhaltung und so weiter
Arbeitsplätze, Infrastruktur, Server und da steht halt einfach mal grob dreitausendneunhundertfünfzig Euro Verlust jeden Monat.
Ja, vier K.
Vier K. Und das ist natürlich ähm.
Sehr traurig, vor allem, wenn man jetzt anschaut, dass die Personalkosten jetzt für wohlgemerkt Markus und Andre und Praktikanten damit äh fünftausendzweihundert Euro,
Arbeitgeber wie heißt der der Arbeitgeber brutto, ne? Arbeitgeber brutto, fünftausendzweihundert Euro für im Prinzip,
drei Personen, die sich da Vollzeit mit beschäftigen, wovon eine Person dann äh oder zwei Praktikanten sind, die äh wirklich ganz, ganz wenig Geld bekommen, ne.
Was natürlich auch als Missstand da gesehen wird, aber man sich einfach nicht mehr äh leisten kann, ne?
Da gab's ja dann auch äh unter dieser dieser Grafik waren dann irgendwie riesige Beschwerden, also waren dann wieder so schöne Kommentare, wo du so
Ich hätte euch ja hier gespendet, aber nachdem ich da eure utopischen Gehaltsvorstellungen sehe, von fünftausend Euro für drei
Personen ähm habe ich konnte mir das überhaupt nicht mehr in Frage, was ihr euch da vergeuden lassen wollt. Also.
Wer wer selber schon mal gearbeitet hat in seinem Leben bei so einer Gehaltsabrechnung gesehen hat, ja? Und jetzt mal irgendwie weiß das ein Praktikant äh da zweihundert Euro bekommt ähm
oder dreihundert, ne? Und das mal alles abzieht, der kann sich ausrechnen, was für ein Nettogehalt Andre Meister und Markus Beckedal haben
Und das äh ist, glaube ich, nicht mehr weit zu einem zu halt dem Gehalt ab, den man besser bei Hartz vier wäre, so ungefähr.
Recht prekär, also das,
jeden Fall jetzt kein, kein, keine äh, äh, keine Einnahmemenge, die jetzt äh, also vergolden, oh Gott, Leute, echt, bitte, ja, also. Und ehrlich gesagt, und wenn schon, ja, also,
Das wär mir äh auch scheißegal, weil äh die Arbeit, die da gemacht wird, wird gut gemacht. Das ist einfach äh nachhaltiger, wie sagt man so schön, Qualitätsjournalismus, ja?
Der uns ja allen so viel Wert äh äh ist und ähm das kann sich durchaus tragen. Jetzt natürlich die große Frage wie,
und ähm ja, jetzt ist man erstmal mit dieser Initiative da rausgegangen und hat gesagt, hier spendet,
im Prinzip. Und es müssten sich jetzt eben Spender finden, die vor allem eben auch regelmäßig irgendwas beitragen.
Ja ähm,
Erstmal möchten sie, sie haben jetzt so eine Spendenrallye und wollen, glaube ich, erstmal insgesamt fünfzigtausend Euro einsammeln, mit denen sie dann ihren momentanen.
Quasi das Minus des laufenden Jahres zwanzig dreizehn auffangen könnten, also viertausend Mal,
Zwölf Monate werden knapp fünfzigtausend. Ähm da das wollen sie quasi auffangen, um einfach mal zweitausenddreizehn,
mit einer schwarzen Null abschließen zu können. Und darüber hinaus wollen sie natürlich dann das Ganze auf eine auf eine solide Finanzierung
stellen mit einem regelmäßigen mit so einer Art regelmäßigen Spendenmodell, ne? Also irgendwie zu sagen komm ein, also quasi ein Freiwilliges Abo,
Anetzpolitik Org. Und äh sie hoffen natürlich,
Eventuell mehr Geld äh reinzubekommen und damit dann die äh Redaktion auszubauen, äh neue Leute einzustellen, Praktikanten vielleicht mal ein bisschen besser zu bezahlen und wenn es halt jetzt richtig dick kommt und der große
große Geld reinkommt, vielleicht auch wirklich die Sicherheit zu haben, nochmal jemanden einzustellen. Und ähm das wäre natürlich äh ist eine,
Eine feine Sache. Ich seh's ja selber, ich bin teilweise, ähm, da ich ja Netzwerk org immer lese und andererseits auch mit den internen Abläufen, dadurch, dass ich da selber, glaub ich, ein Jahr lang war.
Oder länger war bin ich ja ganz gut vertraut damit und ich sehe manchmal da merke ich so selber OK das und das kriegen sie jetzt gerade nicht hin,
wollen sie eigentlich, ne? Also da müsste eigentlich gibt's irgendein Thema, da würde man eigentlich nochmal den und den Artikel zu erwarten, aber die sind gerade einfach nicht dazu in der Lage, weil sie noch andere Sachen beackern müssen und so, weil sie halt auch die ganze Zeit noch andere Sachen im Kopf haben müssen. Und das finde ich eigentlich
Das finde ich eigentlich ärgerlich, weil ich möchte eigentlich, dass Leute, die so eine, ja, so eine wichtige Arbeit machen, ähm dass die halt wenigstens den
Kopf frei haben können und sich nicht
regelmäßig um irgendwelche Vorträge oder sonst was kümmern müssen, um irgendwie äh sich über Wasser zu halten. Ich möchte eigentlich, dass sie da gemütlich, zufrieden sitzen, ausreichend finanziert sind und sich auf ihre Arbeit konzentrieren können. Ähm
Ja, wie gesagt, insbesondere bei Andre, der da total äh Öffentlichkeitsscheu äh
eigentlich sitzt, wie man auch in diesem Video von ihm sehen kann, sich in Sachen reinkniet ähm,
und da wirklich lange ausführliche eigene Recherchen veröffentlicht.
Ja, achttausend Euro sind schon zusammengekommen. Da geht also was.
Das ist jetzt von vorgestern. Ich habe gerade nochmal mit Andre telefoniert, dass der dieses Ding, dieser Spendenstand, der da angegeben wird, sollte da jeden Tag aktualisiert werden. Das wäre also, wenn man jetzt sagt
wenn man jetzt sagt, okay, achttausend Euro ist, glaube ich, der Stand von vorgestern, sagen wir mal, sie haben jetzt inzwischen neun. Das wäre noch nicht mal ein Fünftel. Das heißt, damit werden sie,
nicht mal bis jetzt heute ist der achtzehnte fünfte noch nicht mal bis heute werden sie zweitausenddreizehn finanziert mit diesem Geld.
Ähm das so, um das mal ins Verhältnis zu setzen, ne, wenn man sich denkt, klar äh,
Nö klar ist das eine ist das irgendwie viel Geld, was da auch in wenigen Tagen zusammengekommen ist. Aber da sind ist eben auch viel Arbeit, viel Zeit, viel Infrastruktur hinter.
Und das wäre natürlich mal ganz schön,
Also ich finde das auch als Modell einfach sehr interessant. Sie sagen jetzt, wir wollen Leser finanziert sein, mehr Inhalte liefern, größere Redaktionen haben und wir wollen einfach mal,
diejenigen sein, die auch zeigen, dass es geht, ja? Ich
Ich finde das ja auch ist ja auf eine gewisse Weise, ist das ja sogar sehr riskant, diesen Schritt zu machen als Netzpolitik, org. Zu sagen, okay, wir schreiben uns jetzt dran, oben hier großes Banner, Leser finanziert.
Zack. Und das ist das ist das, was wir haben möchten. Das ist das, was wir im, in diesem ganzen
Netzpolitik, Urheberrechts und sonst was äh Dschungel seit neun Jahren predigen, ne? Direkte Finanzierung durch die Leser äh,
direkte direktes äh Stemmen der Aufgabe durch die Community für die Community, Unabhängigkeiten sichern, äh die Wirtschaft da oder die wirtschaftliche Einflussnahme raushalten. Ähm da ist Netzpolitik,
ORG, das Ding, was da das beste Beispiel schaffen kann,
und ähm wo es glaube ich auch fataler, wenn sie es nicht schaffen würden. Also das wäre ein weiteres Armutszeugnis für die gescholtene äh Netzgemeinde.
Ja, also ähm.
Wir profitieren ja hier auch in dem Programm extrem, von Netzpolitik org, nicht nur, weil da einfach so ein konstanter Newsflow ist und so viel recherchiert wird, sondern äh wir haben ja hier auch den Andre häufiger äh äh zu Gast bereits gehabt, der hier äh auch,
inhaltlich 'ne Menge beigetragen hat ja wir sind trotz Namensnähe nicht dasselbe Projekt ja?
Wenn ihr äh uns äh unterstützt, dann könnt ihr genauso gut auch mal über Netzpolitik org nachdenken. Da ist dann auch sehr der Flatterknopf nicht so weit, ja? Äh
Ich empfehle ja immer sehr äh die Subscribchens bei Fletter, das weiß nicht unbedingt jeder immer
dass man die Knöpfchen nicht nur einmal drücken kann, sondern auch noch ein zweites Mal und damit dann eben einfach ein Abo einrichtet, das heißt in jedem Monats,
Zug, also jede Monatsausschüttung des äh eigenen Flatterbeitrags kann man dann einfach bestimmte Knöpfchen und damit Projekte einfach immer mit drin haben. Und das,
das weiß ich auch aus äh eigener Erfahrung und das ist auch das, was eigentlich alle NGOs und so weiter sagen, Spenden sind gut. Regelmäßige Spenden,
sind besser und zwar jetzt gar nicht mal, weil sie mehr Geld bringen, dann.
Sondern genau, weil sie eine gewisse Konstanz und Planungssicherheit äh schaffen, ja, also man hat irgendwie mehr davon ähm zu wissen, achthundert haben wir sicher und äh,
Schön, wenn's mal äh ein paar mehr werden, als dass es immer so fluktuiert und man vielleicht die achthundert nur so im Mittel hatten, man weiß das aber auch immer auch erst äh am Jahresende.
Gemerkt, dass eben auch grade die,
kleinen Mikrobeiträge bei Flatter einfach eine Menge bringen können, weil sie eben, dadurch wenn sie von so einer bestimmten Masse getragen werden, auch sehr stabil sind. Und wenn ich mir so anschaue, was war hier in der Grafik nochmal die Einnahmeseite, Flatter dreihundert Euro.
Ne, ist wenig eigentlich.
Dreihundert Euro? Na gut, was heißt wenig? Also, es sind dreihundert Euro, ja? Es ist äh.
Ja, klar. Das wollte ich also.
Ist nicht nichts, ne? Es ist äh hier immerhin schon mal ähm ich weiß nicht, die Gesamtkosten sind hier eigentlich auch immer irgendwo,
zusammengerechnet.
Äh sechs sechs neun müsste es ungefähr sein, sechstausendneunhundertfünfzig wahrscheinlich. Der letzte Balken war fünfzig Euro oder so.
Siebentausend sozusagen, ja? Also dreitausend sind irgendwie getragen durch äh die anderen Sachen. Ja, da ist es immerhin schon mal ein Beitrag, aber es könnte eben auch mehr sein.
Nee, ich also wenig, natürlich will jetzt hier überhaupt nicht sagen, dreihundert Euro wäre wenig Geld, das ist natürlich viel Geld. Ähm gemessen an dem.
Dem Aufwand, was also da gibt's halt einen Redaktionsraum, ne. Da sitzen Leute drin, die haben da stehen Computer, da sitzen zwei Menschen, die da als Lebensinhalt haben. Da ist natürlich dann dreihundert Euro relativ wenig. Äh was sie anbieten,
oder was sie jetzt haben, sie haben einen Trägerverein gemacht, also Netz für Tick Ork soll dann von diesem Verein betrieben werden,
und ähm haben auch ein Konto angegeben, was den, wenn man sagt, man möchte sowieso regelmäßig spenden, hätte halt dieses Konto den Vorteil, dass sie das dann nicht mehr weitere Gebühren von abgehen, ne?
Dauerauftrage.
Also wenn man sagt, okay, ich möchte, was weiß ich, das abonnieren im in dem Sinne, also freiwillig abonnieren und richte den Dauerauftrag ein äh von Betrag so und so. Ist ja eigentlich völlig egal, wie hoch dieser Betrag ist.
Äh kann man den halt kann man die Wirksamkeit des Vertrages so minimal erhöhen, indem man eben auch dann direkt überweist.
Statt jetzt über zu aber sie haben sich auch jetzt endlich mal ne, es gibt überhaupt jetzt ein Konto, es gibt,
PayPal-Spende. Ich glaube, sie haben auch einen Bitcoin äh Ding angegeben und so ähm wenn ich mich nicht täusche, irgendwo steht das bestimmt.
Wir wollen auf jeden brauchen auf jeden Fall ein bisschen Spenden und ich finde, dass das halt echt mal das das Community-Projekt wäre, wo man wo man dann auch mal wirklich zeigen könnte, okay Jungs, so professionell, ne?
Wir auch, ja, ja, nicht nur genau, Bitcoin kann man auch direkt spenden. So, jetzt haben wir, glaube ich, äh.
Werbung gemacht.
Genug dafür geworben und auch unsere Disclaimer angebracht, dass eigentlich alle Inhalte, äh die wir haben, von denen.
Übernommen sind.
Nein, das stimmt nicht, das das stimmt nicht. Äh da kann ich auch ehrlich sagen, denn äh ähm also mein meine Hauptquellen sind äh Netzpolitik, Ork und Heise,
Und das sind genau die Punkte, die ich meinte, wo ich dann manchmal merke, oh, da ist ein Thema
früher bei Heisa als bei Netzpolitik org, dann weiß ich bei Netzpolitik in der Redaktion ist gerade wieder die müssen sich grade wieder mit irgendwas anderem beschäftigen oder so oder sind irgendwie,
Ähm.
So, ich bin jetzt mal was hier, weil es gibt nämlich einen Bezahlcode-Link auf der Webseite. Das macht die Sache einfach.
Direktlink für Bezahlcode kompatible.
Ja, das kennen viele nicht irgendwie, aber.
Nee, ich auch nicht. Aber.
Draufklicken ist halt so irgendwie so eine URL, wo die ganze,
BLZ Big äh IBAN, Kontonummer, Tralala Geschichte mit drin ist und dann äh geht dein Bankingprogramm auf und hat quasi die Überweisung schon ausgefüllt und musst nur noch den Betrag eingeben und äh.
Direkte Schwelle Überweisung.
So, jetzt gebe ich hier noch mal den Tarn ein.
Jo krass, jetzt geht mein Ranking Programm an.
Bin bezahlt.
Okay, wir haben bezahlt, ihr müsst jetzt auch bezahlen. So, jetzt haben wir lange genug. So, äh, wir wollen auch noch Geld, deswegen müssen.
Guck mal, jetzt haben wir hier unsere eigenen Themen selbst recherchiert.
Eigenständig erarbeitet.
Das ist ein Thema, das Volk gebracht.
Unterhaltsam unters Volk gebracht. So.
Ja ähm es gab nochmal, ich war noch, wer hat das ja schon vom ersten Mal erzählt, ich war jetzt nochmal ähm als Sachverständiger in einem Ausschuss des Bundestages dieses Mal im im Rechtsausschuss.
Das erste Mal war's der Innenausschuss. Ja, okay.
Im Innenausschuss ähm hatte ich dann in meiner Stellungnahme mich hauptsächlich auf die Sicherheit der D-Mail fokussiert, die da im.
In der Kommunikation mit der Verwaltung ähm und den Behörden dann eingeführt werden sollte, dass man sagt, okay, die Behörden und die Verwaltung des des des Bundes und des Landes, die müssen alle per die D-Mail akzeptieren und,
Ähm dann kann man die Steuererklärung darüber einreichen und und oder derartige Ideen. Und ähm ich hatte ja
denn damals äh vor ein paar Wochen eben ausführlich kritisiert, warum das keine besonders gute Idee ist, weil nämlich die D-Mail keine äh kein ernstzunehmendes Verschlüsselungskonzept in in meinen Augen hat. Und da ähm,
Wegen der mangelnden Ende zu Ende zu Verschlüsselung eben kein ausreichendes Sicherheitsniveau für diese sensiblen Daten,
gegeben ist. Was ich eben verstärkt dadurch, dass eine D-Mail Geld kostet, das heißt, man wird die nur wirklich in den, in den Bereichen verschicken, wo es dann wirklich darauf ankommt,
Das heißt so der der die allgemeine durchschnittliche Vertraulichkeit einer D-Mail ist höher als die einer,
E-Mail, wodurch natürlich dann auch diese D-Mail-Server zu attraktiven,
Angriffsziel werden, dass also so viel so zur Sicherheit hatte ich dann ausführlich da dargestellt, habe ich auch nochmal verlinkt. So und jetzt ging's in den in den Justizausschuss. Also es im Innenausschuss war es das E-Goverment-Gesetz,
Und jetzt kam sie, äh kam ging es in den Justizausschuss, wo es dann um das Gesetz ging. Und da äh hatten sie jetzt vor, zu sagen, okay,
ja
Also auf Deutsch so irgendwie elektronische Gerechtigkeit.
Ich glaube EE Justiz oder sowas. Ich weiß ja nicht.
Das deutsche das ist komisch, ne? Justiz klingt völlig bedrohlich, während Justice irgendwie voll nach Freiheit klingt, ne.
Ja, das heißt halt Justice hat, ist halt auch was anderes, als die deutsche Justiz, ne. Also sind halt zwei verschiedene Dinge.
Ja, ist schon geil, wenn wenn du so einen Gefangenentransporter irgendwie so durch die Stadt fährst, irgendwie die Gitter dran, steht drauf, Justiz, das ist schon noch,
immer ein Bild für äh für die griechischen Götter wahrscheinlich. Na ja, auf jeden Fall ähm Einladung in Justizausschuss und ähm.
Da ging es dann darum.
Sie wollten jetzt die rechtsverbindlichkeit der der D-Melder klarstellen. Da ging's jetzt weniger um die Sicherheit, sondern da fand sich dann so eine schöne Passage drin oder an mehreren Stellen, wo sie sagten, ja.
Wenn, wir haben jetzt ein Problem und zwar
konnten wir die qualifizierte elektronische Signatur nicht so wirklich einführen in Deutschland, die haben die Leute nicht genutzt und da hatten wir das Problem mit den Lesegeräten. Das ist also eine Signatur, die angebracht wird aufgrund einer mithilfe eines Zertifikates, das auf einer Smartcard ist?
Und äh was so ungefähr momentan erst mal würde ich sagen,
keine, also ich sehe da erstmal keine offensichtlichen Designschwächen drin. Ähm und würde sagen, dass das so dem aktuellen.
Stand der, der Sicherheit durchaus entspricht im Zertifikat auf 'ne Smartcard Signatur entsprechend anbringen an ein Dokument und so. Das macht erstmal alles ein relativ soliden Eindruck, ist aber mit dem Nachteil ähm verbunden, dass man irgendwie,
fettes Lesegerät dafür brauche, um eben von dem neuen Personalausweis
irgendwie das Zertifikat lesen zu können. Also lange Geschichte auf jeden Fall gehen wir mal davon aus, dass wir da ein halbwegs vernünftiges Verfahren hätten,
Und jetzt sagen sie also in dieser, in diesem Gesetzesentwurf, ja ähm mit der D-Mail haben wir ein Verfahren.
Dass der das so gut ist, dass wir, dass es der die qualifizierten, elektronischen Signatur ebenbürtig ist. So, was heißt das übersetzt? Das heißt übersetzt, sie wollen,
eine D Mail als ein signiertes, unterschriebenes Dokument,
Annehmen. Das heißt, alles, was ich per E-Mail, per D-Mail versende, äh wird vor Gericht so behandelt, als trüge es meine Unterschrift.
Ist aber natürlich nicht der Fall, weil ich mich nur einmalig bei bei der Anmeldung meines D-Mail-Kontos mit dem Ausweis
authentifiziere und sage hallo, ich bin Linus Neumann, hier ist mein Ausweis, ich hätte gerne ein Demail-Konto und dann bekomme ich ein D-Mail Konto und ab dann,
wird jede D-Mail, die ich nach einer sicheren Anmeldung versende, als als signiert äh erfasst, äh interpretiert. So, jetzt stellt man sich, fragt man sich, okay,
Was ist denn das Signatur? Digitale äh Signatur ist ein Verfahren, mit dem man,
Authentizität und Integrität einer Nachricht sicherstellt. Das heißt, es wird, ich habe meinen geheimen Schlüssel, der wird,
verrechnet mit dem,
Mit dem Inhalt der D-Mail oder mit dem Dokument, was ich versende, da kommt eine Prüfsumme raus und eine dritte Person kann dann anhand dieser Prüfsumme wieder checken,
dieses Dokument, was vorliegt, mit meinem Schlüssel signiert wurde. Wenn sich jetzt eins von beiden ändert, also,
Es ist mit einem anderen Schlüssel signiert oder das Dokument wurde verändert, dann passt diese Signatur nicht mehr.
Also dann könnte ich prüfen, okay, dieses Ding ist nicht von Linus unterschrieben worden. Es ist nicht authentisch oder dieses Ding ist.
Oder nicht dieses Ding ist von Linus unterschrieben worden, also ist dieses Ding nicht,
ist die Integrität dieses dieses Dokumentes nicht gewährleistet. Schönes Verfahren, äh so die Grundlagen dafür haben wir ungefähr seit zwanzig Jahren in der Kryptographie. Wenn nicht sogar noch länger, müsste man nochmal gucken, wann da die ersten Ursprünge waren.
Und äh das ist aber jetzt bei der, bei der D-Melder dann explizit nicht der Fall. Stattdessen soll die D-Mail von dem Provider signiert werden,
Das heißt, ich schreibe meine D-Mail. Die wird von mir an den De-Mail-Server gesendet und da sagt der Provider, ja, ich unterschreibe die jetzt mal für dich.
Und äh,
Um das jetzt mal so zusammenzufassen, heißt es also, die Gerichte sah oder das der das Justizministerium sagt jetzt, in Zukunft können Gerichte bei einem Brief,
Wohnabsender draufsteht und ein Poststempel draufsteht, den behandeln sie bitte so, als wäre er von dem jeweiligen Absender unterschrieben. Das wäre so die ähm.
Äquivalent, was jeder.
Äquivalent, was jeder versteht. Ähm das habe ich dann da vorgetragen,
ähm dass ich das für eine ausgesprochen schlechte Idee halte, ähm hat aber letztendlich dann, glaube ich, wenig wenig Menschen interessiert in der ähm,
der Berichterstattung des Bundestages zu diesem zu dieser Anhörung tauche ich noch nicht mal auf.
Schön, gibt's einen Artikel auf Bundestag DE.
Da steht drauf alles super, alles.
Alle,
äh alle applaudiert äh alle Sachverständigen haben nur gesagt, das muss man unbedingt machen und ähm ein äh Herrn, der noch dort war zu der die Belange der Barrierefreiheit
da vertreten hat. Die wurden nochmal extra betont, aber ansonsten,
nur Jubel auf der Bank, der äh Sachverständigen laut äh Berichterstattung vom Bundestag DE. Es liest sich natürlich ein bisschen anders, wenn man die beiden,
Ähm die beiden Pressemitteilungen des CCC und die beiden Stellungnahmen äh des CCC sich dazu anschaut.
Ja, das sind doch nur diese Unruhestifter aus dem Computer. Naja.
Sind ja nur die Chaoten aus dem Computerclub, ja. So sieht das aus.
Die wollen ja nur unsere Gesellschaft destabilisieren.
Ja, also es, okay, ich, ich muss dann doch mal zitieren, da da steht mir, da waren halt wirklich die meisten Sachverständigen, die da waren, es waren insgesamt acht oder neun.
Es war ein Richter. Die waren, das war natürlich klar, es ist äh es geht um Gerichte, also sitzen da Anwälte, Notare und Richter als Sachverständige und halt ein Chaot. Und dann sagten,
erhalten mehrere der anwesenden Richter,
dass ihn jetzt nicht einleuchten würde, warum ich da jetzt plädiere für ein höheres Sicherheitsniveau, als sie im Moment bereits hätten. Sie würden im Moment ja, könnte man eine Klage offener Postkarte oder auf einem Fax einreichen,
und ihn wäre jetzt da nicht das Bedrohungsszenario bewusst. Also das heißt, er sitzen drei Richter und sagen, Unterschrift, ach komm.
Scheißt doch drauf. Und äh sagten dann, ja ähm wenn da jemand eine Unterschrift fälscht, da haben wir doch ein Gesetzgegen. So ungefähr.
Ah, Mordsdorf verboten.
Muhat ist doch verboten, genau. Ist natürlich, die Frage ist natürlich, dass das kann ich ja niemals nachweisen als jemand, dessen Demailkonto gehackt wurde, dass ich diese nicht geschrieben habe, ne?
Und sie haben es auch nur auf den Anwendungsfall äh gerichtet da bezogen. Das war dann auch ein ein Fehler, den sie in ihrer Argumentation hatten, denn wenn ein Gericht,
selber per Gesetz sagt eine D-Mail behandeln wir als unterschriebenes Dokument, wenn wir sie empfangen,
dann kann das Gericht natürlich nicht in einem Urteil nach BGB oder so, wenn da zwei Parteien sich vor einem Richter streiten, diesen Maßstab nicht an eine Demail ansetzen, so zumindest nach meiner äh Interpretation. Also ein,
Eine spannende äh spannende Situation dort. Ich hatte eigentlich mehr erhofft in dem Moment, wo ich den äh den ähm,
den Juristen dort erkläre, dass die Dokumente, die sie da anerkennen wollen, überhaupt nicht unterschrieben sind von der Person, die da eine Willensbekundung drin tätigt, dass sie in dem Moment hellhörig würden.
Das war allerdings äh nur bei zwei der weiteren Sachverständigen dann der Fall, dass sie sich dafür interessiert haben. Die anderen sagten ähm
appellierten dann eindringlich an den Ausschuss, äh sich da jetzt nicht von irgendwelchen Miesmachern beeinflussen zu lassen, sondern unbedingt sicherzustellen, dass dieses Gesetz jetzt noch,
entschieden wird. Sowat.
Politik live und in Farbe.
Politik live und in Farbe, es war ähm mal sehen, also ich habe ja weiterhin die Hoffnung, dass einfach dieses D-Mail sich niemals durchsetzen wird. Das ist, wie gesagt, im Moment die Option, die einfach für die Gesellschaft die Beste wäre,
Ähm.
Ja das wird sich nicht durchsetzen.
Ja, es wäre, es ist halt ein großes äh äh,
großes Risiko, wenn sich das so durchsetzen würde. Ich würde mir wünschen und ich bemühe mich weiterhin zu vermitteln, dass halt eine Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte E-Mail mit irgendwie so.
Zertifikaten vom von der Bundesregierung für die Bürger. Das wäre echt eine tolle Sache. Das wäre super, das wäre wirklich mal
E-Government auf, auf Weltniveau, ne. Da könnte man wirklich mal was Ordentliches machen. Immer noch die Frage, ob man ähm,
Ob man das jetzt, wie man das jetzt datenschutzrechtlich oder sonstwas äh bewertet und ob man das als als äh
als Zwang oder als Option haben möchte für die Bürger, aber jetzt aus meiner Reihenperspektive als äh auf die IT-Sicherheit wäre das echt mal eine wünschenswerte Sache. Das, also es kann ja eigentlich nicht sein, dass wir bis heute
nicht in der Lage sind, ähm eine ordentliche, digitale Unterschrift zu machen.
Tja, das ist ein Drama.
Es ist wirklich äh bedauerlich, ne? Wer.
Ja, vor allem, sie machen's ja sozusagen bei Elster.
Ja da haben sie jetzt.
Da machen sie es zwar schlecht, aber zumindest also da übertreiben sie's in gewisser Hinsicht schon wieder fast so, ne, aber wenn ich irgendwie mit Elster kommuniziere, also wenn ich meine Steuererklärung abgebe und auch das ist ja sozusagen ein.
Könnte ich auch mit der Post unterschrieben hinschicken, theoretisch, wenn's mir überhaupt noch ermöglicht werden würde, weil das ist ja quasi da herrscht ja sogar schon der digitale Zwang, da geht's ja gar nicht mehr um die Option,
Weiß nicht, ob du das auch schon mal gemacht hast, aber man muss dann so.
Ja, ja, ich habe gerade Verlängerung beantragt.
Na ja, man muss da irgendwie man muss sein ähm,
ein Zertifikat an äh fordern in so einem Prozess, wo man, glaube ich,
Ja, Post kriegt und tralala Postideen. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, was da die Prozesswarte schon eine Weile her
und dann äh muss man sozusagen dieses Sicherheitsloch ja war äh immer wieder explizit dafür öffnen, was ich nochmal besonders albern finde, ja, aber so ist es nun mal implementiert. Und dann muss ich auch noch zusätzlich dem Zertifikat auch nochmal einen PIN eingeben.
Und ja äh dann darf ich dann in diesem schlechten User in der Face da dieses Formular ausfüllen und am Schluss muss ich nochmal meine PIN eingeben. Ja und dann ist es erst offiziell, dass das jetzt wirklich die Zahlen waren.
Wenn's um Geld geht, ne.
Na ja, man könnte deine Argumentation jetzt so für D-Mail interpretieren, ne? Oder wär's halt äh also ich
ich finde, ich würde wahrscheinlich für so eine Lösung plädieren, dass man echt sagt, okay, neuer Personalausweis, zack, Zertifikat rein, äh für solche, für solche Sachen
an Inhalte gebundene Signaturen, denn nur das ist halt eine wirkliche Signatur und äh vom User selber gemacht und so äh könnte man halt
Da könnte man halt dann einmal das Problem überall lösen. Und dann müsstest du nicht für Elster, die jetzt wieder nochmal irgendwo ein Zertifikat bestellen oder sonst was, ne, aber.
Das gilt aber nur für Deutsche.
Elster oder was?
Personalausweis.
Ja ach ja es ist sowieso alles zum Heulen. Ich es ist sowieso alles zum Heulen, ne? Das aber du kannst halt, ich meine, wir werden sie nicht dazu kriegen zu sagen, okay, wir können unsere Steuererklärung mit PGP signieren. Das geht halt nicht.
Nein, das geht nicht.
Ist da das skaliert halt auch nicht, auf, auf, auf so einem Bundesniveau. Und es wird ja auch grade nicht für ein Regierungsniveau geschrieben, sondern von Phil Zimmermann eher genau gegen eine Regierung geschrieben PGP, ne?
Okay, lange Geschichte. Ich wollte das nur noch mal erklären, so D-Mail äh ne,
wird unterschrieben vom Provider und äh mir ist da auch völlig unklar, wer dann dafür haften soll, wenn da mal irgendwie jemand eine E-Mail in meinem Namen äh eine D-Mil in meinem Namen verschreibt und so. Alles ein großes Desaster. Es gibt ja die beiden Stellungnahmen zu, kann man sich nochmal anschauen. Ich glaube, in der nächsten Woche
Gibt's da eventuell auch nochmal eine Radiosendung zu flüsterte mir ein Vöglein? Ähm.
Und es gibt einen Artikel von Sascha Lowe dazu.
Ganz unterhaltsam.
Der sich ganz unterhaltsam wohl liest, ja.
Ja, kommen wir zur äh dem sonstigen Aktivismus. Äh ja, die bedrohliche Gesetzes äh Beschlusslage drängt die Massen auf die Straße. Nicht.
Also es war so, es es war letzten Sonntag ja Demo gegen Bestandsdatenauskunft.
Komplett verpasst. Noch nicht mal davon gehört, wurde dir denn ausgerufen?
Das war die äh das war die Piratenpartei und die sind da irgendwo hinten am Innenministerium rummarschiert. Am Sonntag.
Piratenpartei. Am Sonntag am Innenministerium.
Es war in ganz vielen, es war in ganz vielen Städten Deutschlands ähm und in Berlin, da wir beide uns ja hauptsächlich in Berlin aufhalten, war das irgendwie die Piratenpartei, die sich da irgendwo es gab da eine Demo-Rute, aber das war alles irgendwelche Straßennamen, die mir jetzt nicht so bekannt waren
irgendwo hinten am Innenministerium wollten sie darum gehen.
Aber die Gesellschaft für Informatik war da auch.
Nee, äh äh da äh das äh ist nochmal was anderes. Also ich gucke jetzt mal ganz kurz ähm.
Lange Geschichte, Samstag. Samstag war das, Samstag äh Berlin. Steht da gar nicht drin.
Wie auch immer. Also es waren Demos. Der war halt äh also in Berlin war das dann so, dass da keine Sau war. Also es waren sehr, sehr wenige Menschen. Ich glaube, da war irgendwie von.
Letztendlich dann dreihundert die Rede. Äh je nachdem, wer da welche Zahl vorgetragen hat oder hundert oder so, auf jeden Fall sehr, sehr wenige Menschen, die da an dieser Demo teilnahmen. Und ich muss zugeben, auch ich,
habe dann nicht dran teilgenommen, weil ich äh da die dann noch die Stellungnahme geschrieben habe und auf Twitter, dann last es eh keine Sau und mir dann dachte, okay, dann,
Dann äh gehe ich auch nicht hin.
Das alte Problem.
Ja ähm.
Ist klar, ist immer der selbe Effekt, das muss einfach eine gewisse kritische Masse muss irgendwie absehbar sein, bevor sich irgendwie auch noch der letzte äh aus dem Sitz hebt, das ist vollkommen normal.
Ja, ich wäre eigentlich schon gerne da gewesen. Ist natürlich jetzt auch äh äh.
Das ist eine gute Ausrede gehabt. Außerdem war ja gutes Wetter.
Es war gutes Wetter, aber deswegen hätte natürlich auch wieder dieser Demo zu trinken. Man, also insgesamt würde ich mal sagen, diese Demo hätte sich unter Umständen eine bessere Route suchen können,
Also irgendwo da einmal hinten durch's Nirvana zu marschieren äh am Samstag oder Sonntag am Innenministerium, wo halt äh,
Die letzten Ministerium waren die machen sechzehn Uhr Feierabend so oder oder wann auch immer sie Feierabend haben, machen die das da. Da sitzt keiner am am Samstag oder Sonntag und kloppt Überstunden und sagt, oh, da sind gerade dreihundert Leute auf der anderen Seite des Ufers oder sowas. Also das hat.
Lasst mal hinfahren.
Lass mal, ja? Nee, äh okay.
An dem Sonntag oder so was demonstrieren müssen.
Ja Brandenburger Tor oder geh irgendwo geh irgendwo hin, wo dich wenigstens Leute sehen.
Ja, meine ich ja, da wo die ganzen Picknickdecken ausliegen.
Aber doch nicht im Wald.
Ja
Aber wie gesagt, wir können hier, wir können nur Bedarf, wir können nur das Ergebnis bedauern, wir dürfen da jetzt nicht großartig so gut. Weil wir haben, wir haben gar nichts gemacht, insofern äh vielen Dank an diejenigen, die da waren und äh
schade, dass ihr da alleine dann da äh vergammelt seid. Ähm es gibt natürlich immer noch die,
Hoffnung und die schmale Hoffnung auf den Bundesrat in der ganzen Bestandsdaten, Auskunftsangelegenheit, da gibt's jetzt die Gesellschaft für Informatik, äh die dann eben die gravierenden, verfassungsrechtlichen Mängel in diesen äh,
Gesetzesentwurf ähm bemängelt und den den äh Bundesrat,
auffordert, da irgendwie nachzubessern. Ähm.
Insbesondere wurde dann wird halt kritisiert, dass äh es immer noch keinen Unterschied gibt zu den, dass die die,
meine Güte, Entschuldigung. Das ist immer noch nicht differenziert wird, dass eben diese IP,
auf Schlüsselung, dass das halt das das große Gefährliche Ding dahinter ist und dass dass die weiterhin da als Bestandsdaten äh gesehen werden, ne? Also man,
der morgen wird sich dann der Innenausschuss diesmal des Bundesrates dann mit dem Gesetz auseinandersetzen. Aber wie wie Frank ja schon hier sagte, das ist alles SPD.
Ja. Ja, interessant finde ich, dass die äh GIDA die Gesellschaft für Informatik halt auch nochmal auf dieses neue Grundrecht, äh das wir ja eigentlich haben, aber bisher von jedem äh ausführlich missachtet wird ähm hingewiesen hat. Also,
Vertraulichkeit und Integrität der äh persönlichen IT-Systeme, ja?
Derzeit noch so recht keiner drauf hören, aber das ist natürlich äh meiner Meinung nach,
langfristig, sprich, wenn's dann mal auf Verfassungsrang behandelt wird, äh ein sehr entscheidendes Argument. Ich glaube nicht, dass die Verfassungsrichter hier selbst erlassen das Grundrecht da äh so ohne Weiteres außen vorlassen werden.
Gut, kommen wir zu den Dingen, die äh die Leute wirklich bewegen.
Oh, ist das bei den anderen Sachen nicht der Fall, meinst du?
Seien wir realistisch, wenn's ans eigene Internet geht, dann werden die Messer gezückt. Ja.
Ist einfach kaputt. Ist kaputt.
Soll es auch noch kaputter äh gemacht werden, dann gab's eine schöne Studie, die hier bei Heise äh besprochen wurde,
vom äh von der Bundesnetzagentur.
Mal so ein bisschen äh gemessen haben, wie es denn so aussieht und äh was denn nun tatsächlich für Bandbreiten auch wirklich erzielt werden und inwiefern das mit den Aussagen der Provider darüber, was diese Anschlüsse theoretisch so,
leisten könnten, wie denn das so zusammengeht und ja Überraschung, es wurde festgestellt, das das Abweichungen.
Ja, wurde also sozusagen Abweichungen festgestellt und äh entsprechende Kundenbeschwerden scheinen dadurch auch realistisch zu sein. Das Ganze ist eine in einer ausführlichen Studie, die auch als PDF,
verfügbar ist, dokumentiert worden.
Ja, also äh,
Ich fand da ja Kommentar dann durchaus zutreffend so nicht auszumalen, wenn nicht, wenn da jemand noch in kompetenteres drangegangen wäre, der hätte vielleicht noch länger als zehn Jahre gebraucht, um festzustellen, dass die Bandbreiten, die uns versprochen werden, nur selten erzielt werden. Ja, also das
Ähm,
das ist jetzt wirklich nichts äh überraschend Neues mehr, dass äh man seine Bandbreite sehr selten äh äh oder dass man sehr selten die Biss zu Bandbreite äh in seinem in seinem.
Das ist das, was bis zusagt.
Genau, das ist ja genau, also das äh ja. Bis zu heißt eben bis zu.
Könnte auch mal theoretisch irgendwann mal vielleicht so sein.
Genau. Wobei das natürlich auch eine messtechnische.
Wir treffen ja hier auch nur nur Aussagen, die bis zu totaler Wahrheit gehen.
Bis zu war, bis zu bis zu absolut war.
Ja
Ähm das Problem bei so einer Erfassung ist natürlich.
Wenn jetzt, weiß ich, wenn ich was runterlade, gibt's halt so viele Stellen dazwischen, die es theoretisch bremsen könnten.
Und auch tun ähm unter anderem natürlich ist YouTube, wenn ich das jetzt so als Beispiel nehme, nicht daran interessiert, mir mein Video viel schneller zu schicken,
Als ich es brauche, weil sonst würden sie halt verschwenden, ne. Also sie geben mir so viel Video, dass ich einen guten Puffer habe, ähm,
irgendwie ordentlich durchgucken zu können, aber sie mir geben mir natürlich nicht sehr viel mehr, weil
alles, was sie mir gesendet haben und ich mir nicht angucke, ist vergeudet, ja? Und wenn man das halt mal auf die Größe von YouTube skaliert, dann stehen da schnell äh ein paar äh Kohlekraftwerke, nur um das
sicherzustellen, ne? Also und was dann noch irgendwie an an eventuellen Traffic da entsteht, der der eben
völlig sinnlos ist. Ähm schön sieht man das äh bei Torwrents, da ist es tatsächlich sehr einfach möglich, seine Bandbreite dann auch wirklich mal,
zu erreichen, dadurch dass man davon ganz vielen immer ein bisschen gesendet kriegt, schafft man's mit Torens.
Eigentlich immer noch am besten durch diese vielen verteilten Verbindungen seine Bandbreite mal auszureizen.
Ähm,
aber immerhin, wir haben's mal dokumentiert. Jetzt ist die Frage, wie was man daraus interpretiert, ja? Ähm.
Es gibt man könnte jetzt sagen, okay, ähm.
Die Provider können nicht das, was sie als Biss zu versprechen tatsächlich liefern, könnte man sagen, okay äh die bewerben ihre Sachen falsch. Äh man könnte aber natürlich auch sagen.
Ähm also,
Ich ich find's eigentlich schon so in Ordnung, dass ich einen Biss zu bekomme. Es wäre halt schön, dadrunter noch einen mindestens stehen zu haben.
Dass sie sagen, du kriegst immer mindestens zwanzig M Bild und teilweise, wenn wir's irgendwie hinkriegen, sogar bis zu fünfzig.
Na gut, ich meine Mitte mindestens, da kommt da noch sehr viel mehr zum Tragen, dass die Gegenseite ja auch mitspielen muss, ne.
Ähm ja, das ist.
Also es kann ja ein ganz anderer Provider dafür verantwortlich sein, wenn da irgendeiner sein sein Rauter falsch konfiguriert und alle Kunden, die an diesem Provider angeschlossen sind, äh sind einfach langsam zu erreichen, beziehungsweise es gibt
dann einfach nicht die entsprechende Konnektivität zwischen den Providern dann kannst du halt noch so einen schnellen Pfad haben so. Das ist alles sehr schwierig nachzuweis.
Mich interessiert aber nicht die Einzelverbindung. Ich habe doch nicht nur eine Verbindung. Wenn ich online bin ähm,
ich aus allen Richtungen und ich baller auch in alle Richtungen. Ich will da weißt du? Und deswegen finde ich diese diese mindestens Angabe finde ich schon gut. Ich möchte immer mindestens Not also und wenn ich's einfach nur,
Auf meinen persönlichen, nicht ausgelasteten Server, der irgendwo steht, äh einfach äh über NetCut äh mein
Backup mache, ähm dann möchte ich, dass das halt am Ende an meiner Fritzbox steht, zack, bumm, zwanzig, äh, Mbit werden hier nicht unterschritten oder so. Okay,
Ist alles nicht so einfach, müssen wir vielleicht auch nicht ins Detail gehen. Was da das Problem ist, dass natürlich die Provider jetzt sagen können,
diese Studie auch nehmen können, um zu sagen, da haben wir's doch, unser Netz ist überlastet.
Das ist doch genau das, was wir sagen und deswegen müssen wir jetzt hier äh das Ganze funktional kaputt machen,
und drosseln. Das wären, das ist halt auch äh eine eine Argumentation, die man auf Basis dieser Studie machen kann. Deswegen sind diese das haben ja wissenschaftliche Erhebungen so an sich, dass wenn sie
ordentlich gemacht wurden, dass man sie immer noch in verschiedener Weise interpretieren kann. Und insofern,
ist es halt schwierig, was eben diese äh Modelle angeht, ne. Aber.
Grund,
ein Grundproblem ist natürlich auch die Flatrate, also äh beziehungsweise, dass teilweise nicht,
funktionierende Geschäftsmodell was Provider sich dahinter gedacht haben, indem sie immer mehr theoretische Maximalbrandbreite zur Verfügung gestellt haben und dabei beim
Flat geblieben sind und offensichtlich nicht gesehen haben, dass sie da auch nochmal eine Infrastruktur, Investition tätigen müssen, sondern in den letzten Jahren einfach nur gemolken haben. Also da kommen viele
Problemfaktoren.
Ja, ich denke, die politische Debatte sollte sich aber jetzt zumindest auf Netzneutralität einerseits und auf äh den Unsinn der Drosselung äh insbesondere bei stationären Anschlüssen
konzentrieren. Ich denke, das ist etwas, wo man relativ klar machen kann, dass das Unfug ist äh beziehungsweise jetzt nicht unbedingt den Entscheidern, äh ja, aber zumindest den Betroffenen, um dann vielleicht äh mehr zu schaffen, als nur ähm.
Kleine Horden, die sonntags ums Innenministerium herumschleichen.
Das ist richtig und beide Probleme, die du gerade nanntest, also Verletzungen der Netzneutralität und äh klassisch, also im Prinzip funktionales Abschalten des Internetanschlusses sind,
keine äh akzeptablen äh Reaktionen auf.
Also man sollte einfach mal Dienstag Nachmittag bei den Telekom-Zentralen irgendwie, wie vorstellig werden, sich da vorstellen und einen Ghettoblaster anschalten und den passenden Sound trägt, den liefern aber hier noch als Bonustrick äh gleich nach.
Ja, also Internet darf nicht funktional kaputt gemacht werden.
Absolut nicht. So, Kurzmeldung nehme ich mal an. Die Enquete ist jetzt vorbei. Ist jetzt vorbei.
Ist jetzt vorbei. Die die legen jetzt irgendwie ihren Abschlussbericht, glaube ich, heute oder morgen im Bundestag vor. Ja, aber äh da ist ja auch nichts Neues mehr gekommen. Also.
Wir hatten ausführliche mit äh Konstanze ja schon,
und reflektiert, wer die Sendung noch nicht äh gehört hat, kann das ja da nochmal nach äh hören, wie auch nicht anders zu erwarten war
ein dürftiges Fazit gezogen, weil am Ende dann doch alles irgendwie in Parteienproports hängen bleibt und äh
man sich schön auf die Schulter klopfen kann, das man tolle Ehrenkalt gehabt hat. Jetzt haben wir mal über Internet geredet, jetzt ist es aber auch mal gut, jetzt können wir mal wieder über was anderes reden.
In interessanten Zusammenhang wird das dann nochmal gestellt auch zu den äh Piraten, wo man natürlich wohl letztendlich könnte man jetzt,
Nach drei Jahren Enquete und dem Piratenkram und so weiter ähm kann man natürlich schon sehen,
dass die Strategie der der etablierten Parteien, die sie ja mit dieser Enquete-Kommission irgendwie verfolgt haben, äh dann doch aufgegangen ist, ne, dass man sagt, okay, ja, äh Netzpolitik ist jetzt
haben wir so als Thema
assimiliert. Wir haben jetzt Netzpolitiker, wir haben profilierte Netzpolitiker in unseren Parteien Peter Tauber freut sich dann irgendwie auch noch und sagt ah selbst die CDU hat jetzt Netzpolitik irgendwie im Regierungsprogramm stehen,
Und äh die etablierten Parteien sind natürlich alle damit erstmal ganz happy.
Dass sie den Teil, bei den ihnen die Piraten,
Äh irgendwie in die Wade zwicken konnten. Jetzt irgendwie so ein bisschen in ihre Partei reingetreten haben,
reingezogen haben, während sich die Piratenpartei bei allem, was über Netzpolitik hinausgeht, nicht profilieren konnte,
Das heißt, äh im Prinzip können sie sich jetzt hinstellen und sagen, ja super, ne, wir haben gelernt, aber so eine Notwendigkeit für die Piratenpartei ist dadurch jetzt einfach nicht mehr gegeben,
Enquete ist zum Abschluss, sie definiert jetzt die äh die Leitlinie äh der Bundesregierung im Bereich der Netzpolitik, wir haben Netzpolitiker in allen Parteien, warum brauchen wir jetzt hier noch eine Netzpartei, ne?
Ähnlich wie ein und genau diesen Punkt sich eben in anderen wie in anderen Bereichen zu positionieren, der ist eben für die Piratenpartei nach aktuellem Stand äh auch schiefgegangen.
Ja, ich kriege das Projekt, das muss auch mal überdacht werden, aber kann man ja vielleicht zum späteren Zeitpunkt nochmal drauf kommen. Das wäre jetzt nicht die Diskussion aus äh brechen. Was haben wir noch?
Ja, da äh das habe ich mir reingemacht, weil wir da so ein schönes äh,
wir hatten ja vor einigen Sendungen sprachen wir über O2-Telefonika, die ja sagten
sie wollen jetzt irgendwie die Benutzer die die Bewegungsdaten ihrer Nutzer irgendwie zu Geld machen und da hattest du ja dann angemerkt, dass man daraus natürlich auch tolle Dienste machen kann, wie zum Beispiel eine Vorhersage darüber,
wo sich Staus befinden und ähnliches und dass da dass da natürlich Informationen sind, aus denen von denen die Allgemeinheit profitieren kann,
Während sie die Gegenposition ist, okay, das ist irgendwie eine eine Überwachung der Nutzer oder sowas. Und jetzt äh hat äh Telefoniker Herr äh vorgestellt, dass sie irgendwie ein Produkt haben, welches,
in dein Auto eingebaut wird,
Und irgendwie über GSM und sonst was. Faktoren erfasst wie Geschwindigkeitsüberschreitungen. Endlich über GSM, über GPS,
Geschwindigkeit und dein Bremsverhalten, dein Fahrverhalten einfach erfasst, wird Auto merkt einfach, wann wird's bewegt? Und teilt das über GSM oder äh UMTS, dann,
Einer Zentrale mit, auf deren Servern, wo dann ähm.
Eben im Prinzip gespeichert ist. Ach guck mal hier, der ist nachts in Schlangenlinien äh die Landstraße mit hundert lang gefahren. Ähm und diese diesen Datensatz, der wird dann eben,
den kannst du dir dann selber anschauen, ja? Also sowas ähnliches wie wie so ein so ein so ein Jogging Programm für
so eine iPhone Jogging-App halt für dein Auto und das Ganze wird dann, da kriegst du am Ende wirft dir dieses Ding dann Punkte ab und sagt so, okay, guck mal hier, du bist irgendwie ein Fahrer, der Kategorie fünf oder so und,
Das wiederum sollst du dann deiner Versicherung geben können auf,
Dass diese dich äh besser einschätzt, dein Risiko besser einschätzen kann und dir einen faireren Tarif äh.
Er macht, ja? Momentan ist das ja so, die Versicherungen gehen halt irgendwie nach dem Auto und nach deinem Alter,
So ungefähr grob und ein bisschen dein Einkommen oder irgendwelche komischen Dinger und seien die dann so und so viel kostet das, dein Auto zu ähm äh zu versichern. Wenn du irgendwie mit achtzehn da hingehst und möchtest irgendwie einen einen Golf GTI versichern,
wissen die schon, dass du den halt nächsten Monat um Baum wickelst und entsprechend wird dann halt auch deine
Versicherungssumme aussehen. Und mit dieser Datenbasis wollen sie halt dafür sorgen, dass die Versicherung dann sagen können, ja hier machen wir du fährst gut, mach mal billiger für dich.
Unglaublich. Äh,
Ich sehe da noch interessante Betätigungsfelder für so digital äh Forensiker und so äh binär Hacker. Weil das ist natürlich jetzt die optimale Methode. Ja, das ist sozusagen die neue Form des Tunings,
Ja, während du äh bisher eher ein Softwareupdate bekommen hast, damit dein Auto irgendwie äh die doppelte äh Performance irgendwie abrufen kann, ja, obwohl das eigentlich so vom Hersteller nicht vorgesehen war, zumindest offiziell nicht,
äh kannst du dir jetzt sozusagen diese Box da reinschrauben, spielst dir dann das passende Softwareupdate auf und diese dieses Gerät bestätigt sozusagen permanent,
was du doch für ein zurückhaltender, entspannter Fahrer bist, während du eigentlich Nachts die ganze Zeit mit hundertachtzig irgendwie durch die City rauscht.
Zwei Punkt null.
Ja, ne, so und das Gerät sagt halt einfach die ganze Zeit, also der ist ja hier, also sowas von
umsichtig und keine dreißiger Zone verletzt, also es ist wirklich der Hammer, ja, da würde ich doch nochmal glatt nochmal zwanzig Prozent runtermachen. Und ich meine, der
finanzieller Anreiz, der dadurch entsteht, der ist so enorm, ja? Ich meine, das Potential, was ja
tausende von Euro wahrscheinlich über sehr kurze Zeiträume, die du ersparen kannst, so dass äh sagen wir mal der Raser von heute natürlich äh mit Handkurs da sich seinen Softwarepatch irgendwie aus Russland holen.
Wie macht man das? Also man könnte so einen Fahrerkäfig um das Modul selber machen, wo man dann das GPS äh dem Ding selber gibt und sagt, jetzt sind wir gerade hier. Jetzt fahren wir gerade hier wieder schön im verkehrsberu.
Ach, ich bin gerade schnell. Ja, ich bin auch gerade auf der Autobahn.
Ähm oder auf dem Nürburgring, ja? Äh einfach das Ding fährt die ganze Zeit im Nürburgring im Grafen. Ähm,
Man könnte natürlich versuchen, die Datenverbindung wieder über über äh das Mobilfunknetz hergestellt wird, irgendwie zwölf und da irgendwie einfach die ganze Zeit falsche Daten hinzuschicken, während man das Modul.
Das kriegen die nicht. Ja, ich meine, also theoretisch wäre das natürlich schon denkbar, ja, bloß der Aufwand, den sie da reinstecken werden, Security-technisch, das kennen wir ja nun schon, den Spaß. Also.
Also für für die Hacker unter uns, das wird auf jeden Fall nochmal ein spannendes Teil.
Ja, vor allem es bedeutet ja letzten Endes auch nur, du wählst quasi jetzt auf Leute, die das nicht haben wollen und ja
du auf einmal Kosten ab, weil äh jetzt die ganzen Phligmatiker und Rentner äh bauen sich das Teil ein, sparen sie sich nochmal zwanzig Prozent bei ihrer Versicherung,
Also muss natürlich die Kohle von woanders kommen und äh das Modell, dass sozusagen das Risiko eben auch über alle verteilt wird und damit auch die Kosten
geht dann halt immer weiter auseinander. Das ist so ein bisschen wie das du unterschreibst, dass niemand anders mit deinem Auto fährt und nur Leute, die irgendwie äh mindestens dreiundzwanzig sind et cetera.
Die ähm der Punkt, dass es eigentlich so ein ökonomischer Zwang wird, daran teilzunehmen.
Der ist natürlich nicht uninteressant, ne? Die Versicherung sagt einfach, ach äh wie, du willst nicht äh diese schöne Modul in dein Auto einbauen? Na dann müssen wir dich leider wie jemanden behandeln, der einfach die ganze Zeit nachts besoffene Autorennen fährt. Ähm.
Wir wissen's ja nicht.
Wir wissen's nicht und entsprechend entsteht dann also als freiwillig kann man dieses Verfahren dann auch nicht bezeichnen.
Der nächste Punkt, der dann einfach zwangsläufig passieren wird, ist
dass dieses Gerät dann tatsächlich sagt, äh hier der Typ fährt mit hundertachtzig über die Landstraße, obwohl er halt äh fünfzig Meter weiter auf der Autobahn fuhr,
weil einfach die Software nicht zuverlässig funktioniert und du natürlich irgendwie keinerlei Möglichkeit hast, das zu belegen und dann einfach die Versicherung, der tut uns leid, also so wie sie fahren, also wieso wie wie ich fahre. Na ja, hier ist, steht auch schwarz auf weiß, die Software hat immer Recht
Ja, äh wir wissen, Programmierer sind die Krone der Schöpfung und äh machen nie Fehler und von daher muss das ja alles stimmen.
Das heißt, deine deine zukünftige Sorge ist nicht mehr, dass du geblitzt wirst, sondern dass deine Versicherung dir kündigt oder dir eine höhere äh einen höheren Tarif schickt, ne.
Ja, so und und die und ich meine,
Das ist dann einfach auch eine interessante, informatische äh Herausforderung. Ähm ja, wie stellen wir eigentlich in Zukunft sicher, dass,
Softwareeinheiten, die eben für so kritische Einschätzungen verantwortlich sind, auch nachweisbar das Richtige tut, TM, ja?
Das ist nun mal sehr schwer, allein schon weil sie sich ja auch auf externe Informationsgeber, wie eben GPS Satelliten-Navigation et cetera äh verlassen muss, ähm diese gar nicht kontrollieren kann. Also du kannst ja gar nicht sicher sagen
dass du immer ein korrektes Signal bekommst.
Nächster Einfallsteil, ich denke, sie werden das Ding dann auch an den Kanus von dem Auto anschließen. Ähm und da irgendwie vielleicht noch äh das Verhalten abgreifen äh.
Ja, du kannst dann irgendwie auch von außen ran, also die Hackbarkeit von solchen, du kriegst es nicht sicher, da äh wir werden das erleben, dass Leute sich nachts an eine Kara ran
schleichen und irgendwie Zugriff zu Bordelektronik erhalten über irgendein Weg ja, wenn's nur von unten im Motorraum ist, irgendeinen Stecker abziehen, wo einfach der Campus drauf liegt, der ist nicht
in dem Maße so geschützt und authentifiziert, das lässt sich wahrscheinlich im Auto auch nur sehr eingeschränkt machen, zumindest denke ich nicht, dass das äh derzeit sehr extensiv getan wird,
mal einer drüber nachgedacht hat, aber äh ja, da ist schon ein Weg drum herum und äh es kann dir halt einfach jemand auch mal einfach die äh die Firmenwerder neu flaschen und dann erzählt die halt, was weiß ich, was die alles erzählt. Also da das das klingt jetzt mal wieder alles so ein bisschen wie,
äh so vorausschauende Verschwörungstheorie, aber,
Mal ehrlich, meine du nickst auch nur. Ja, also äh wer ein bisschen Plan hat von Elektronik und, und, und, und, und der Realität der Softwareentwicklung und auch der Realität der Sicherheit weiß, das ist einfach nur eine Frage.
Gewinnaspekt ausreicht und in dem Moment, wo sich da genug Geld sparen lässt oder du jemand anderem, weil es in deinem Interesse ist, genug schaden kannst dadurch, dann wird es einfach stattfinden so, ja und äh
die Härtung solcher Systeme wird sich da nicht durchsetzen, weil das Ganze dann immer mal wieder hier durch solche Rechtsausschüsse durchgeht, wo dann äh die Experten sagen, na hier, das ist alles scheiße und es stinkt
ja? Äh,
Und äh ja und Finsternis war auf den äh Augen äh den Gesichtern der Arbeiter und dann geht das halt irgendwie da oben in diesen Bundestag rein und die hören einfach nur so korelle und äh und Gospelchöre und alles ist super, ja.
Ja, wieso? Hier, wie der Bitcoin hat uns gesagt, das ist alles sicher.
Also ich bin ich bin auf jeden Fall freue ich mich, sage ich mal, auf den Vortrag beim einunddreißig C drei zu diesen Dingern.
Und das das Rennen, das Rennen, wer ihn halten darf, äh ist dann halt jetzt eröffnet, ne?
Ja, genau. Viel Spaß. Ja, der Bereich der äh nacheilenden Legitimation.
Ja, das ist jetzt wieder so eine Sache, äh ähm.
Das ist wieder ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein Meister hier. Ähm,
ein Meister, ein Meisterwerk, der äh hat sich nämlich hm.
Und da wird's jetzt wieder äh hat sich also äh mit dieser Funkzellenabfrage in Dresden. Da war ja die ähm,
Februar zweitausendelf, äh Dresden Nazifrei Demo
Und da gab es ja dann irgendwie ganz, ganz viele Funkzellen abfragen. Äh bei, von der insgesamt mehr als eine Million Telekommunikationsverbindungen betroffen waren und sechzigtausend Menschen in der identifiziert wurden
ähm die sich eben an den entweder an der Gegendemonstration,
oder an der Nazi Demonstration, die da jährlich in Dresden stattfindet, äh beteiligt haben oder eben auch nicht, weil sie einfach nur in deren in diesen Gegenden wohnten, ja? Ähm.
Und das LKA Sachsen hat dann anlässlich dieser Demo eben so eine Rasterfahndung in der ganzen Stadt durchgeführt. Und da sollte jetzt dann irgendwie gegen geklagt werden.
Und ähm da hat jetzt ein Gericht geurteilt, nämlich das so und so
Amtsgericht Dresden, was also sagt, ja, nö, also kommen hier eine Million Datensätze, sechzigtausend Menschen. Das ist doch äh durchaus verhältnismäßig, da brauchen wir uns jetzt hier nicht äh auseinander äh zu setzen. Wer wer äh zu einer
zu einer Demonstration geht, der muss sich ja nicht wundern, dass da äh die Polizei irgendwie,
mal guckt. Die Betroffenen sind nicht benachrichtigt worden, auch wieder ein ein häufiger Kritikpunkt bei solchen ähm,
solchen Sachen, das kann ich wiederum bestätigen, weil ich damit sehr hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit auch einer der äh Betroffenen bin.
Allein in Sachsen stellt André so schön nochmal fest, wird alle vier Tage eine Funktion Abfrage gemacht. Ja, also das das GSM-Netz ist längst äh zu einem,
Also ist in Deutschland oder insbesondere in Sachsen längst zu einem Überwachungsnetz für die Bevölkerung geworden? Was äh wir in anderen Ländern immer so schön äh dann auch kritisieren, ne?
Gibt immer mehr Leute, die dann äh Handys nicht mit zu Demonstrationen nehmen. Das halte ich für die falsche Reaktion auf auf solche Bedrohungsszenarien. Ich würde eher mehr Handys damit hinnehmen.
Aber ähm.
Mehrere Handys. Ja. Ja oder man leiht sich einfach von jemandem Handy.
Oder was man auch gut machen kann natürlich ist äh solange wir das noch dürfen, das werden sie uns ja auch bald wegnehmen die äh ähm Prepaid-Karten, die man sich ohne Registrierung auf den Namen irgendwie holen kann,
ähm und Handys gibt's beim Flohmarkt, ja, sowas mal äh,
Sowas kann man einfach gut äh in der Tasche haben und auch einfach regelmäßig tauschen oder äh sind Karten Tauschbörse oder sowas,
fünf Euro, Vodafone gegen äh vier Euro neunzig T-Mobile oder sowas.
Sind da auch Möglichkeiten. Aber klar, Funktionen nachfragen werden gemacht, es ist ganz klar, man kann gucken, wer war zu welchem Zeitpunkt, wo
und das wird auch gemacht und wenn wir da nicht irgendwie massive äh Legislative gegen haben, wird das einfach auch weiterhin genau so stattfinden,
keine Sorgen zu machen.
Man braucht so einen digitalen Demobedarf, ne, das wäre nochmal eine schöne Idee für so ein Fachgeschäft, wo man sich dann so einen, für einen Tag, so ein iPhone äh leihen kann.
Ja, aber da bin ich dann auch schon wieder Fatalist, weil äh wenn wir jetzt, wenn wir wirklich jetzt massiv anfangen
und äh schleppe mir jetzt ähm Prepaid-Handys dahin. Dann werden sie sagen, ja die Kriminellen
nutzen Prepaid-Handys, weil sie anonym sind, wir müssen jedes Handy äh maximal auf Namen registrieren und machen jetzt alle nicht registrierten Prepaidkarte,
machen wir zu und äh so weiter und wir müssen da mehr Vorratsdatenspeicherung betreiben und mehr Überwachung machen, weil die, weil unsere momentanen Methoden irgendwie nicht funktionieren
kannst ja machen, was du willst, wenn du, wenn du versuchst, dich irgendwie gegen diese Methoden zu wehren, dann steht sofort der auf und schreit wieder irgendwas. Also das ist wirklich eine eine was die Überwachung Sachen angeht, ist das eine,
enorm äh enorm frustrierendes Feld, weil du da wirklich einfach, egal, was du machst, die werden einfach nur noch lauter schreien.
Und ähm.
Funkzellenabfragen sechzigtausend Leute irgendwie äh überwachen, das jetzt als verhältnismäßig zu bezeichnen bei einer Demo, wo,
nichts, gar nichts. Da sind am Ende irgendwelche Bundestagsabgeordneten äh angeklagt worden, weil sie einen Polizisten nicht schnell genug aus dem Weg gegangen sind. Ne, also solche,
So eine und gleichzeitig zweitausendelf war ja das Jahr, in dem da die, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche, indem die Nazis das Haus angegriffen haben. Und die Polizei daneben stand.
Hundert Meter weiter,
Ja, da war ein äh irgendwie ein äh ein Zentrum von von alten alternatives Wohnzentrum in in Dresden. Das wurde da wirklich, das war.
Ich glaube, das waren die ersten, die einzigen Aufnahmen, die ich jemals gesehen habe, wo wirklich der bildlich der Mob ein Haus angreift,
Nazis, weiß ich nicht, zwanzig, dreißig sind das mit Steinen äh und was die nicht alles hatten, ein Haus angegriffen.
Die Bullen stehen da in dem.
Die Bullen stehen daneben und gucken in die andere Richtung und passen auf, dass die Linken hier nicht die Nazis stören.
Und gleichzeitig wird das alles mit der darfst du Sachsen ist unglaublich, also ist wirklich was in Sachsen los ist
Seht zu, dass ihr da noch rauskommt, äh weil irgendwann muss müssen wir da wieder eine Mauer drum bauen. Also ich kann ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, Sachsen ist unglaublich. Es ist irrsinnig, was in diesem, was in diesem Bundesland abgeht.
Ja, die lösen auch mittlerweile Bayern eigentlich irgendwie so ein bisschen ab, was so ja.
Boah, ja, aber habe schon längst, also und den, den Verantwortlichen für die Funkzellenabfrage, den sie ja dann erst erst am ersten Tag da rausgeholt haben und gesagt haben, hier, der, das alles nicht gut, was der gemacht hat, ne? Die haben's ja schon längst nach oben befördert.
Den haben sie aus der Schusslinie nach oben befördert. Der ist, ich habe da jetzt irgendwann mal vor vor zwei Jahren.
Polizeichef Dresdens.
Ja, der ist doch jetzt irgendwie äh ich ähm.
Nochmal nach.
Verlinke ich, da das habe ich bei bei Netzkritik Org damals geschrieben, aber also was da unglaublich, also die die stecken da alle unter einer Decke im Faxen.
Unglaublich. Ja.
Breaking News. Gut, aber nicht alle ähm Gerichte entscheiden äh gleich.
Noch ein zweites äh Urteil Oberlandes Oberlandgericht Oberlandesgericht Köln.
Dich das.
Aber muss ich das ja immer fragen, wie das aussieht.
Und hier gab's eine Entscheidung, die sich auf die Quellen TKÜ äh bezieht.
Genau, da geht's um die, um die digitalste Software, also den den O-Zaft ist Trojaner, der vom CCC auseinander.
Bundestrojaner oder Staatstrojaner, wie auch immer man ihn irgendwie jetzt äh nennen möchte. Ich bin da etwas verwirrt.
Bin da jetzt auch vorsichtig, sagen wir mal den, also den.
Den Trojaner, den O-Zapf, ist der also von vom CCC analysiert und veröffentlicht wurde. Ähm da wurde jetzt das Zeugriminalamt abgeurteilt,
weil sie mit Hilfe dieser Software rechtswidrig geschnüffelt haben und zwar,
argumentiert das Gericht dort. Äh nicht äh nicht ausschließlich über diese äh über die Unangemessenheit dieses dieses Gerätes, sondern weil es keine unverzügliche Löschung unangemessener Aufnahmen.
Sichergestellt hat.
Keine unverzügliche Löschung. Ach so, okay, dass das was sozusagen mitgeschnitten wurde, was aber nicht verwendet wurde, nicht sofort gelöscht wurde. Also es war jetzt,
mit irgendwie was macht ihr denn da? Das ist doch alles verboten, sondern äh ihr habt da so einen Teilaspekt äh äh nicht berücksichtigt und wie konntet ihr nur.
Ja, also.
So nach dem Motto, lasst euch doch nicht erwischen.
Ja, so wie ich äh äh,
Also letztendlich so, wenn eine staatliche Überwachungsmaßnahme nicht besonders geschützte Kommunikation,
Unverzüglich löschen kann, dann darf sie nicht eingesetzt. Das ist eben eine das ist
dass er diese Anforderung ähm, dass, wenn wenn du halt mit deinem äh mit deinem kriminellen Kumpel diskutierst am Telefon, dass du erstmal
äh dreißig Sekunden Telefonsex machen muss, damit die Abhör äh Leute sich herausschalten. Das sieht man ja immer in den Gangsterfilmen, der äh
der USA welcher ist das denn, ne? Also gibt's ja mehrere, wo die dann oder ist das Good Fellers oder Casino oder so, also.
Gesehen, echt?
Ja, natürlich wird, also ich glaube, das ist Casino, wo sie dann, wenn sie telefonieren, dann telefonieren immer erst die beiden Frauen,
fangen an über irgendwas privates zu reden, weil dann die Ermittler auflegen müssen.
Die äh Gangsterbosse dran und äh ja, ja, ich weiß nicht, ob das so pfiffig ist. Äh ich weiß, ich würde,
für diese Methode würde ich jetzt nicht keine Garantie aussprechen, dass sie
dass sie tatsächlich funktioniert. Aber genau für diesen Fall, da müssen sie eben löschen, dürfen sie nicht abhören, ne? Und da gab's doch auch schon mal irgendwelche äh welche Fälle von Telefonsexprotokollen dann in den Akten oder so, wo dann auch ähm,
äh äh Gerichtsprozesse dran äh kranken oder so. Und.
Könnten wir uns ja vielleicht auch rechtlich ein bisschen absichern hier. Das wäre doch vielleicht auch mal eine Methode.
Ja, sie können uns gar nichts. In dem Podcast haben wir nämlich erst Telefonse gemacht und dann.
Sind wir gegangen.
Ähm genau, es hätte uns keiner zuhören dürfen. Wir haben das gar nicht veröffentlicht.
Und hier ist das irgendwie äh ähm.
Oh da ging's dann sogar noch um die Diskussion mit ihrem mit dem Verteidiger, ja also noch viel schlimmer. Ähm so viel dazu, also äh ich glaube viel mehr als das diese Quellen-TKÜ eben immer noch an ganz, ganz vielen ähm,
Sachen krank, ist äh offensichtlich. Und ich bin auch nach wie vor da der.
Aus technischer Perspektive der äh Überzeugung, dass man eine Quellen-TKÖ,
die den juristischen Anforderungen an die Quellen TKÜ genügt, nicht umsetzen kann. Und ich denke, dass das ein,
Akzeptabler Zustand ist und würde deshalb vorschlagen, weder das Gesetz zu ändern, noch weiter sich zu bemühen, eine Software
entwickeln zu lassen, die ausschließlich Quellen, Telekommunikationsüberwachung betreibt, weil das eben nicht möglich ist.
Hm. So Linus, wollen wir mal eine Woche Pause machen, dann wird's auch immer gleich ein bisschen länger, ne?
So ist das.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ja, also das waren jetzt so die Themen, die ich jetzt irgendwie in den letzten zwei Wochen rausgesucht hatte.
Ja und fahren wir jetzt äh solange die mir nicht so einen über so einen GPS-Überwachungsdinger ans Fahrrad schnallen ähm.
Kann ich eigentlich jetzt gleich noch fahren, wie ich will, ne? Mache ich dann auch.
Notfälle angehalten wirst. Nimm einfach dein Telefon und ruf erstmal jemanden an und führ ein intimes Gespräch.
Kleinen Moment, ich muss mal kurz, muss mal kurz hier mit jemand unter.
Naja, das ist wirklich nur, weil wenn du halt also äh würde ich mich nicht drauf verlassen, auf diese auf diese Telefonsexummer, ja?
Ja
Oder die Treppen, das ist, glaube ich, Casino. Die treffen sich dann immer bei Ärzten. Es ist so äh solche Scherze, äh irgendwie oder bei Anwälten oder so. Bei ihrem Anwalt treffen sich dann die.
Könnte man sich noch bei Journalisten treffen, aber ich glaube, das ist mittlerweile auch nicht.
Würde ich auch vorsichtig.
Und ja äh äh sorry, wenn ich jetzt irgendwelche Sachsen unter unseren Hörern äh beleidigt habe oder du auch, ne, also hier die Nähe zu Bayern ist natürlich auch immer ähm oder beide.
Sie, ich bewerte nur, was ich sehe. Ja, ich bin ja ein großer Sachsen äh Fan, also so rein kulturell äh habe ich da nichts auszusetzen, aber es ist halt einfach äh politisch ist das Ganze wirklich fragwürdig.
Ich war da auch letztens noch mal in Dresden. Der ist ja auch wirklich eine eine äh eine schöne Stadt, aber was was da also
ich kann das auch gar nicht verstehen. Vielleicht müsst ihr mal, da müsste mal sich jemand nochmal
genauer oder haben sich wahrscheinlich auch Leute mit beschäftigt. Müssen wir nur mal gucken, was vielleicht so Anne Roth oder oder auch Andre äh dazu schreiben zu dieser ganzen Sachsensache, die die da ja schon seit längerer Zeit äh auch ein Auge drauf haben.
Man muss, ich kann mir wirklich nicht erklären, was da in Sachsen los ist. Also die.
Ja, ich verstehe es auch nicht.
Wir müssen denen helfen, das mit der Mauer war ein blöder Spruch, wir helfen euch da raus, Jungs. Ich glaube, ich habe bei mir könnt ihr immer aufs Sofa, wenn ihr irgendwie rübermachen wollt.
So, jetzt machen wir aber Schluss hier.
Ja, tschüss.
Äh das war's. Bis zum nächsten Mal, tschau.